d
una multitud que une fuerzas para
denunciar la violencia racial por una
vez las comunidades asiáticas de todo el
país se reunieron para expresar su ira
juntos
[Aplausos]
me siento inspirado unido a los estamos
haciendo escuchar
desde el comienzo de la pandemia hace un
año las agresiones contra personas de
origen asiático se han disparado más del
114 por ciento sólo en los ángeles
también vino a dar testimonio en nombre
de su comunidad vietnamita desde esta
semana tres salones de uñas vietnamitas
recibieron una carta ahora capilar que
todos los asiáticos son tan fríos que
huelen tan mal su fealdad y su olor me
dan
tengo el corazón roto desde muy doloroso
para muchos el discurso anti chino del
ex presidente de donald trump provocó un
aumento de los actos racistas cuando el
ex presidente de eeuu se refiere al
coronavirus como el virus chino o la
gripe kung fu
es un insulto a todos los asiáticos y de
hecho nos consideran culpables de un
virus que no tiene nada que ver con los
que vivimos en eeuu
[Música]
los principales blancos son los adultos
mayores que son atacados en la calle o
en las tiendas los ataques suelen ser
grabados por cámaras de vigilancia como
en este caso en el que un hombre de 91
años es lanzado violentamente al suelo
sin razón alguna nos encontramos con tam
y su madre quien de 76 años en un parque
del condado de orange aquí es donde está
estadounidense vietnamita fue abusada
verbalmente mientras caminaba
son de agua un día estaba caminando
cuando unas personas que caminaban hacia
me dijeron usted aléjate de ella
en el virus
pero sobre todo tengo un poco de miedo
porque soy mayor y ando solo la uac van
a ser súper pero se ha ido ante la
indiferencia de las autoridades la
generación joven decidió tomar cartas en
el asunto todos los jueves unos cuarenta
jóvenes se reúnen en esta intersección
de koreatown de los avales para proteger
a los más vulnerables crearon un sistema
de patrulla ciudadana
esto es gas pimienta desesperante tipos
pero rocía en la cara de los que te
atacan no es dañino pero los hace huir
'estamos y como resultado del estallido
de la violencia anti asiática sentimos
que tenemos que defendernos y proteger a
nuestra comunidad estos voluntarios
recorren el barrio y se dividen en
grupos de cinco personas
necesito a alguien que se haga cargo de
llamar al 911 si las cosas
en la calle distribuyen folletos y les
explican a los habitantes cómo presentar
una denuncia en caso de agresión tras
las últimas agresiones que debemos
asegurarnos de que todo el mundo esté a
salvo gracias este barrio tiene la mayor
comunidad asiática de los ángeles donde
en los últimos meses se han multiplicado
las agresiones
hay muchas agresiones que nunca se
denuncia estamos aquí principalmente
para garantizar la sanidad pero también
para intervenir en casos de emergencias
la policía de los ángeles está en la
reputación de no habernos ayudado mucho
snap y en el pasar de guerras a veces
también acompañan a personas mayores
algunas de las cuales tienen miedo de
salir solas desde el comienzo de la
pandemia las autoridades han registrado
más de 3800 denuncias de discriminación
la mitad de ellos en california
esta discriminación tiene sus raíces en
la historia de las minorías asiáticas en
eeuu
tal vez a algunos estadounidenses les
sorprenda el estallido de esta violencia
anti asiática verbal como física pero
nosotros los estadounidenses de
ascendencia asiática llevamos mucho
tiempo sufriendo esta violencia desde la
llegada de los primeros inmigrantes al
país no muy lejos y aquí está el centro
de los ángeles
en 1871 19 hombres y niños chinos fueron
asesinados por una multitud de varios
cientos de personas
este incidente esta masacre no fue un
caso aislado
estos incidentes siempre han ocurrido en
eeuu primero contra los inmigrantes
chinos luego contra los filipinos y
después cuando los japoneses acabaron en
campos de concentración durante la
segunda guerra mundial así que hay una
larga historia de violencia anti
asiática amenazas de la violencia
siempre está presente en eeuu y a punto
de estallar cuando hay tensiones
económicas y raciales una multitud
diversa acudió a rendir homenaje a las
víctimas del tiroteo de atlanta que dejó
8 muertos en un salón de masajes un
crimen que no fue calificado de racista
por la policía
nosotros también hacemos parte de esa
minoría sufrimos crímenes racistas
sufrimos violencia y estoy exhausta
pero también estoy orgullosa de todos
los que están aquí porque se trata de la
nueva generación de estadounidenses de
ascendencia asiática nacionales que no
tienen miedo de hacerse escuchar vía
facebook está inspirado por black lips
matters este movimiento de justicia
social contra el racismo sistemático se
extiende ahora a todas las minorías más
allá del color de la piel como llegamos
hasta aquí somos parte de este país
hemos participado en la construcción de
este país no hay razón por lo que esto
suceda sólo porque somos diferentes
físicamente dentro de unas décadas todos
nos veremos un poco diferentes y quizás
eso asuste a algunas personas pero lo
siento soy mamá de y los mestizos y esa
es la base de este país así que tendrán
que acostumbrarse
aquí todo el mundo espera que este
despertar de la conciencia de las nuevas
generaciones erradique por fin el
racismo sistémico que ha asolado a eeuu
durante décadas